let's talk a little bit about congruence
congruence and one way to think about
congruence it's it's really kind of
equivalence for shape so when in algebra
when something is equal to another thing
it means that their quantities are the
same but if we're now all of a sudden
talking about shapes and we say that
those shapes are the same
the shapes are the same
size and shape then we say that they're
congruent and just to see a simple
example here
i have this triangle
right over there and let's say i have
this triangle right over here
and if you are able to shift
if you are able to shift this triangle
and rotate this triangle and flip this
triangle you can make it look exactly
like this triangle as long as you're not
changing the lengths of any of the sides
or the angles here but you can flip it
you can shift it you can do any and
rotate it so you can shift let me write
this you can shift it
you can flip it
you can flip it and you can rotate if
you can do those three procedures to
make these the exact same triangle to
make them look exactly the same then
they are congruent and if you say that a
triangle is congruent let me label these
so let's call this triangle a
b
and c and let's call this
d let me call it x y and z
x
y
and z so if we were to say if you we
make the claim that both of these
triangles are congruent so if we say
triangle
a
b c is congruent and the way you
specified it looks almost like an equal
sign but it's an equal sign with this
little curly thing on top we write a
little bit neater so we would write it
like this if we know that triangle abc
is congruent to triangle
x
y
x y z
that means that the their corresponding
sides have the same length and their
corresponding angles and the
corresponding angles have the same
measure so if we make this assumption if
we or if someone tells us that this is
true then we know then we know for
example that a b is going to be equal to
x y the length of segment a b is going
to be equal to the length of segment x y
and we could denote it like this
and i'm assuming that these are the
corresponding sides
and you can see it actually by the way
we've
we've defined these triangles a
corresponds to x
b corresponds to y and then c
corresponds to z right over there so a b
side a b is going to have the same
length as side x y and you can sometimes
if you don't have the colors you would
denote it just like that these these two
lengths are have or these two line
segments have the same length and you
can actually say this and you don't
always see it written this way you can
alway also make you could also make the
statement that line segment a b is
congruent is congruent to line segment
x y but congruence of line segments
really just means that their lengths are
equivalent so these two things mean the
same thing if one line segment is
congruent to another line segment that
just means the measure of one line
segment is equal to the measure of the
other line segment and so we can go
through all the corresponding sides if
these two characters are congruent we
also know we also know that
bc
we also know the length of bc is going
to be the length of x y x of y z
assuming that those are the
corresponding sides and we could put
these double hash marks right over here
to show that this one
these two lengths are the same and then
if we go to the third side
we also know that these are going to be
halves the same length or the line
segments themselves are going to be
congruent so we also know that the
length of ac
the length of ac is going to be equal to
the length of xz is going to be equal to
the length of xe we not only do we know
that all of the sides or the
corresponding sides are going to have
the same length if someone tells us that
a triangle is congruent we also know
that all the corresponding angles are
going to have the same measure so for
example we also know
we also know that this angle's measure
is going to have this is going to be the
same as the corresponding angles measure
the corresponding angle is right over
here it's between this orange side and
this blue side or this orange side and
this purple side i should say and
between the orange side and this purple
side and so it also tells us that the
measure
the measure of angle is this bac
measure of angle bac is equal to the
measure of angle of angle y x z
measure of angle let me write that angle
symbol a little less like a
measure of angle y x z
y
x z we could also write that as angle b
ac
is congruent to angle y
x z and once again like line segments if
a one line segment is congruent to
another line segment it just means that
their lengths are equal and if one angle
is congruent to another angle it just
means that their measures are equal so
we know that those two corresponding
angles have the same measure they're
congruent we also know that these two
corresponding angles have the same
measure and i'll use a double arc to
specify that this has the same measure
as that so we also know that the measure
the measure of
angle
abc
abc is equal to the measure of angle
xyz
x
y z and then finally
we know
we finally we know that this
angle if we know that these two
characters are congruent that this angle
is going to have the same measure as
this angle as its corresponding angle so
we know that the measure of angle acb
acb is going to be equal to the measure
of angle xzy
x z y now what we're going to concern
ourselves a lot with is how do we prove
congruence because it's cool because if
you can prove congruence of two
triangles and all of a sudden you can
make all of these assumptions and what
we're going to find out and this is
going to be what we could we're going to
assume it for the sake of kind of an
introductory geometry course that this
is an axiom or a postulate or just
something that you assume and let me
actually just write this down
so
an axiom
very fancy word postulate
also a very fancy word it really just
means things that we're going to assume
are true an axiom is sometimes there's a
little bit of distinction sometimes
where someone will say an axiom is
something that's self-evident or just it
seems like a universal truth that is
definitely true and we just take it for
granted you can't prove an axiom a
postulate kind of has that same role but
sometimes you can say well let's just
assume this is true and see if we assume
that that's true what we can derive from
it what we can prove if we assume it's
true but for the sake of a introductory
geometry class and really in the most of
mathematics today these two words are
used interchangeably an axiom or
postulate just very fancy words for
things that we take as a given things
that we just will assume we won't prove
them we will start with these
assumptions and then we're just going to
build up from there and one of the core
ones that we'll see in geometry is the
axiom or the postulate that if all of
the sides are congruent or if the
lengths of all the sides of the triangle
are congruent then we are dealing or we
are dealing with congruent triangles so
it's sometimes called the side side side
postulate or axiom
we're not going to prove it here we're
just going to take it as a given so this
literally stands for side side side
side side
side and what it tells us is
what it tells us is if we have two
triangles
if we have two triangles
and so let's say that's and that's
another triangle right over there
and we know that corresponding sides are
equal so we know that this side right
over here is equal in length to that
side
we know
that this side right over here is equal
in length to that side right over there
and we know
and we know that this side over here
is equal in length to this side over
here
then we know and we're just going to
take this as an assumption that and we
can build up off of this we know that
they are congruent that triangle
that triangle that these two triangles
are congruent to each other i didn't put
any labels there so it's kind of hard
for me to refer to them but these two
are congruent triangles and what's
powerful there is if we know all of the
corresponding sides are equal then we
know they're congruent and then we can
make all of the other assumptions which
means that the corresponding angles are
also equal
so that we know that that's going to be
congruent to that or have the same
measure that's going to have the same
measure as that and then
that is going to have the same measure
as that right over there and to see why
that is a reasonable why that is a
reasonable axiom or a reasonable
assumption or reasonable postulate to
start off with let's take one let's
start with one triangle
so let's say i have this triangle right
over here so it has that side and then
it has that side and then it has that
side right over here
and what i'm going to do is see if i if
i have another triangle that has the
exact same side lengths is there any way
for me to construct a triangle with the
same side length that is that is
different that can't be translated to
this triangle through flipping shifting
or rotating so we assume this other
triangle is going to have the same a
side that's the same length as that one
right over there so i'll try to draw it
like that
roughly the same length we know it's
going to have a side that's that length
so it's going to have a side that's that
like let me put it on this side just to
make it look a little bit more
interesting
so we know it's going to have a side
like that
so i'm going to draw roughly the same
length but i'm going to try to do it a
different angle and we know it's going
to have a side we know it's going to
have a side that looks like that it's
going to have a side that looks like
that
and so let me i'll put it right over
here
it's about that length right over there
and so clearly this isn't a triangle in
order to make it a triangle i'll have to
connect i'll have to connect this point
to that point right over there and
really there's only two ways to do it i
can rotate it around around that little
hinge right over there if i connect them
over here if i connect them over here
then i'm going to get a triangle that
looks like this i'm going to get a
triangle that looks like this
which is
which is really
just a flipped am i visualizing it right
yeah just a flipped version you could
rotate it a little bit back this way but
then you'd have the magenta on this side
and the yellow on this side and then you
could flip it you could flip it
vertically and then it would look
exactly like this our other option
to make these two points connect is to
make that is to rotate them out this way
and then the yellow side is going to be
here
the yellow side is going to be here and
then the magenta side and then the
magenta side is going to be right over
here and that's not magenta
the magenta side is going to be just
like that and if we do that then we
actually just have to rotate it we just
have to rotate it around
to get that exact triangle so this isn't
a proof and actually we're just going to
start assuming that this is an axiom but
hopefully you see that it's a pretty
reasonable starting point that if all of
the sides all the corresponding sides of
two different triangles are equal then
we we are going to we know that they are
congruent we're just going to assume it
is an axiom for that we're going to
build off of that they're congruent and
then we also know that all the
corresponding angles are going to be
equivalent